he had him on after he was named the new
coach of the los angeles charges and
he's back after his first
draft as head coach of the los angeles
chargers he is brandon staley how are
you brandon
i'm doing great rich thanks for having
me how was that draft room as the hc for
the first time
what was that like a lot like game day
um this year no fans um so
uh just a you know a really good
environment three days a lot going on
but uh felt like you know we had a
really good setup
you know tom telesco and his group are
you know just a really um sharp outfit
and we've really gotten to know one
another over these
you know past you know three or four
months and just felt like we were
prepared
uh for the weekend and felt like we kind
of executed our plan at a high level
and what's it like to look at the
offense the uh the defensive staff and
say where took this offensive player
sort of a shoe on the other foot
the good thing is uh there's a lot of
transparency in the process
our guys know that we're we're gonna do
what's best for the chargers and uh
we're awfully happy
um with how it went in that first round
of course and before we do get to rashan
slater i mean but you have i guess
been in that position before right as a
defensive coach and you're like
you know uh boy i wish i could get that
guy instead it's somebody else from the
other side of the ball
i know you're all one big happy team
usually but i'm just wondering if you've
ever been through that experience before
yourself yeah i think
what you're hoping for is that you put a
team out there that's capable of winning
every week so
that requires both sides of the ball in
a kicking game offering at a high level
so
um i think uh you know that may be a
little bit of a political line but i
think it is true
okay you're playing both sides of the
aisle is what you're saying yeah right
we got to be right down the middle now
so uh but you guys know that
we're a lot better football team uh with
rashaan slater of course because it
protects the jewel
the crown jewel that's uh back there at
quarterback that so many teams are
hoping
their draft choice at the position this
year turns into this fall
like what happened with the chargers
last year what did you like about
rashaan slater yeah i think he just fits
the critical factors for the position
he's really athletic
strong really good balance and body
control um
he's instinctive he really knows how to
play the game uh as you
are aware he's got really good
bloodlines his dad played 11 years in
the nba and
you can see that he's that type of
athlete but i think coming from pat
fitzgerald's program
we have a lot of respect for pat just
the type of competitor he is and then
you know being able to join up at a
premium position i mean when you're
talking about tackles in the nfl those
are premium positions
uh and to be able to get that kind of
value um and that type of you know with
that type of person uh we just felt like
it was a great fit for how we're trying
to build this
offensive football team and then we're
because obviously he works he's a smart
kid uh he's a northwestern kid
um and you know he's we're showing a
photograph of him
uh right now on our screen of him
blocking chase young
who uh damn near was the defensive
player of the year in the nfl last year
so you know he can handle that
competition were there any fraught
moments with all the trading going on
in front of you with uh 10 and 12
swapping spots and
20 coming up to 11 and you're sitting
there at 13 and this is the kid you
might have been targeting all along
and what was that like yeah i think our
intel uh going into it i i mean we
you know we anticipated rashan going in
the top ten i mean we we felt like he
was that caliber or player and then
just we also knew that with the
quarterbacks and the you know kind of
the skill players on offense that
uh you know possibly some of these
corners that it could it could it could
fit right and i think that
once uh he got past carolina we felt
like
you know hey there's a chance and then
um you know felt like there was still an
outside chance
dallas could take him uh and then when
you know they went
um another direction when they went with
micah we we knew that we had him
yeah and that so that that is so cool
but
so you get that call from selection um
square from uh from from the
headquarters at 345 park with the
with the cowboys selected and you must
you guys must have erupted in the room
something like that with this because
there's a lot of quarterbacks
there were a lot of happy a lot of happy
people and it's one of those uh
things where you know what we did in
free agency with our
our line and we just felt like this guy
is going to fit in with that group
so well he plays left tackle it wasn't
like hey you got to move him to left
tackle he plays left tackle
um and then just you know how we're
trying to play
and who we're trying to play with
rashaan's just an outstanding fit
how was your first uh phone call as a
head coach
uh welcome to the team type phone call
to a draftee that was your first
what was that like for you very exciting
and you know that uh someone's dream's
coming true
so i take that you know call really
seriously
um because that moment's gonna change
his life and
at the same time we get to team up so i
just wanted to make sure that he
would enjoy it i don't know how much he
heard because it's pretty loud
in those back rooms but uh just try to
be sincere and
um you know also tell them how excited
we are to get them here so
uh it was it was special and of course
you know we talk all the time about
quarterbacks and how they want certain
things and i know you got a young one
so he hasn't reached that veterans
status yet of
of of you know draft for me
but this has to be a good call you make
to justin herbert right hey we got you
the left tackle let's go to work you and
i
you know for sure i think that um you
know i think what justin knows is that
we're going to try and do everything we
can to to give him the jet the best
chance to be successful and
and certainly i think what we did in
this off season with with our offensive
line
i just think that you know definitely
you know
proves that and um we know what an
outstanding player
he is and he's only going to get better
and the way he can get better is if
the people in front of him are playing
at a high level branded staley uh head
coach of the los angeles
chargers here on the rich eisen show um
so then you take
another bloodline except this one is
straight from the national football
league and ahsante samuel
jr what did you like about him and walk
me through some of the other guys in
your draft that you
you're very pleased to get yeah i think
asante is the type of defensive back
that we really believe in playing with
um
he can play man-to-man from bump from
off
he's got position flex to go inside he's
got
ball judge in the deep part of the field
um he's got really good
movement and level two um when you have
to play off and
you have to be able to see the
quarterback and the receiver um he can
really key and diagnose that way and
then
you know this guy can get you the ball
rich i think that that's something that
we really value in the defensive
backfield people who
can get you the ball um and he's an
outstanding open field tackler so
uh you put in the bloodlines and man you
feel really excited about this pick and
we feel like he's going to make our
secondary um you know a lot more
complete and i know his teammate darwin
james fellow no
i know he was awfully excited he kind of
he kind of called his shot in the
morning meeting
before the draft so i got to give darwin
some props on that one
hopefully the football gods were looking
out for us what do you mean what do you
mean he called his shirt
he just said don't forget about the
knolls you know and you know you know i
knew what he meant
so you mean you didn't look at your
your your notes and say what is there a
safety name
knowles that i'm missing right now you
got it from right for you
yeah uh but um no that was just one of
those you know
side stories it's uh always a highlight
you know it makes the draft more
interesting but
uh you know you know rich i really like
what we did on offense
you know i felt like josh palmer is a
wideout just evaluating all these
secondary players rich
he just this guy kept showing up and
showing up the way he played against
georgia you know how all those db's that
got drafted from georgia bama
patrick certain and then you know just
the way he played it and competed at the
senior
bowl i just feel like he adds to a group
you know
might get you know mike williams and
keenan allen are to the premier white
outs and
the nfl and be able to add josh to that
group we've got some young receivers
jalen guyton tyron johnson uh joe reed
we just feel like
you know this guy's a weapon this guy
can play outside uh and the nfl can move
inside
so feel really strongly about him and
then we got trey mckinney from georgia
tight end that can really play on the
line rich which is kind of
becoming a more rare thing um
you know and feel like played at a
really high level the best conference in
the country
uh so i feel like he can kind of give us
that you know on the line element
you know we added jared cook in free
agency we like donald parham but
i feel like trey mckinney can really add
to that group and then
you know we took a developmental
offensive line from nebraska this guy
you know
set a career record for starts at
nebraska brendan hymas
he kind of gives us guard tackle flex
rich you know feel like this guy's going
to add to that room give us
you know that young depth learn from hey
corey lindsley and brian balaga and
odayabushi matt feiler you can kind of
learn and grow and improve so
i felt really good about that and then
we took this back from missouri that i'm
a really big fan of i
we had this guy stacked a lot higher
larry roundtree he was second team all
sec
he's showing up all over the movie
against georgia bama all these great
fronts
this guy can see he's got balance body
control
he can pass protect so i'm kind of you
know we're really fired up about him and
then on defense
we took chris chris rump from duke who
kind of fits that edge style
player that you know we played with in
the past you know whether it was the
rams bears
or broncos and just a complete player
guy has upside he can play special teams
which is kind of rare for an edge player
um his dad is an nfl coach so he's got
really good makeup really good
bloodlines and
um just feel like he's going to add to
that group with joey and chenna and
kyler fackrell so
and then we took a safety uh from
georgia in the seventh round mark webb
he's really versatile he played kind of
all over the secondary at georgia
um and you know feel like you know he's
got a pro body
outstanding special teams player was a
former receiver
then moved to defensive back and then we
took nick nieman from iowa
really athletic long linebacker you know
kind of side note he went to my wife's
high school
sycamore high school in illinois so i
called him and told him he is the second
most famous sycamore
uh alum because my wife is in the
athletic hall of fame there damn
straight
okay so i said you know nick you know i
love you but your second
best sycamore alum you know and so he
you know this guy was in shock he just
got drafted so
i don't think he had any idea what i was
talking about but um
it is the truth so so this guy gets
drafted and you start talking about your
wives in that ha
in the in the hall of fame in the same
school
yeah i mean it was just a preview of
things to come when he gets here i just
wanted to be
i just wanted him to know the real head
coach that he was playing for
but we're really excited about him he's
a coach's son as well but just a really
you know two-year starter at iowa you
know his brother
plays for the chiefs and um he's just a
really long
athletic tough instinctive player and
very productive kirk ferentz we have a
lot of respect for him so
um you know a pretty you know deep class
good balance between offense and defense
and like i mentioned before i think that
really is the key you're trying to build
a balanced team
and i feel like our draft kind of
reflected that well brandon staley
charges head coach here on the rich
eisen show do you feel i know this is
kind of a loaded question to ask a coach
but i'm going to ask it anyway
certainly here in los angeles you know
uh rams
um uh stan kroenke we all know is the
man who
put a lot of cronky dollars to actually
uh buy the stadium and build the stadium
in a manner that the chargers are also
in and you know the uh the the rams made
a big splash in getting matthew stafford
do you feel you're overlooked not only
in
in this town but also maybe the division
the
the nfl writ large what do you think
of that you know i don't have a strong
sense of that uh rich to be very honest
um
i've kind of said this before been asked
you know similar question i feel like
uh rich coming here i just i i really
want our team
uh to focus on being as good as it can
be i feel like that's how you get to
ultimately where you're capable
of going um the nfl is you know to me
one of the most competitive places in
the world and
you start looking around and um you're
going to lose sight of what's in front
of you and so what we're trying to do
here is create something different
something new
really be as good as we can be uh trying
to push
it as far as we can every single day
that's what we've been doing since we
joined up with these players a few weeks
ago
and i think i know that if we do that
we've got good enough players to compete
with anybody
and so that's been my message to the
team um
and hopefully um you know we'll be able
to play that way
uh come to fall plus you got a humble
kid that's right at the center
uh behind you know under center and
shotgun he sure helps
you know yeah but i mean look at that
that's what you keep hearing though um
is that this is the kid that everybody
hopes that
um that everyone that just got drafted
can be like you've got
a unicorn in the in the sense of what
everybody from the outside is viewing
justin herbert to be
and um this this that's now been placed
in your care i mean that's a significant
um player that you've got right there
and uh what's your relationship
with him like can you walk us through
anything open the door on something for
me
yeah definitely it's he's a it's a big
responsibility and
um you know the biggest component of the
job and
i've just i've really enjoyed getting to
work with this guy every day
um just being able to you know get to
know him you know we had an event at the
stadium you know a week ago or whatever
that was for season ticket holders and
you know my boys were able to meet him
for the first time you know and just
the type of person he is um just so
genuine
so authentic um you know just i think
what people love about him is he's not
manufactured he's just himself
and he's just one of the guys i can see
his leadership style
express itself on a daily basis because
um
you know our guys just love being around
him so all that draft stuff from last
year
it's hard for me to even believe that
that was something that people were
saying about him
because everyone loves this guy and he's
such a hard worker
and you know as you know he's so sharp
you know his mind is is going to be one
of his biggest assets
um so you know i just uh really enjoyed
uh getting to do football with him kind
of provide a different lens you know
from the defensive side really kind of
give him that double education um and
this offense is an offense that i know
well
um because it's kind of the offense that
i grew up with you know joe lombardi is
a guy that i've known for a really long
time
um so that relationship i feel like i
can you know
serve as a coach both ways you know
offer them that defensive perspective
but then
you know i know this offense this is the
offense that i know the best so
um it's been a lot of fun working
together and um
you know he just continues to improve
and i think that's the other thing rich
is that he's just at the beginning i
mean he this guy's gonna get a lot
better
and that's what we're focused on is
really working at his game
um and making sure that uh you know
every single day we're together
um that he's getting one step closer to
being you know the player he's capable
of being yeah have you uh
are you going to keep uh him away from
getting his hair cut by the strength and
conditioning coach
i said i said that's also a great asset
of yours is your hair
so let's let's keep that going um i know
you know it's good to go either way
though so uh he's got he's got
flexibility that way but he took his
elite quarterback here and he turned him
into a cast member of stan
by me i don't know i don't get it you
know what i'm saying like normally you
neck up i would have
no problem with justin herbert but that
was a that was a big question mark for
me
you know yeah he's got he's got a good
sense of humor about it too so
he uh doesn't take himself too seriously
all right i think it's also a good trait
of course it is um thanks for the call
again i think you remember the last time
we
we spoke when you would just uh become a
member of uh the los angeles chargers
after being the dc with the rams and
then the hc
now the lac uh i i you remember what i
brought up with you
since i'm coming to hollywood park as
well coach right remember
yeah a lot's happened since that last
call but i do remember so yes nfl
network is moving
its offices and studios to sofi stadium
at hollywood park
um have you sussed out the parking
situation for me in the interim between
our conversation
i did and so we had that event there at
the the stadium a week ago
and with with you in mind and with the
with the run rich run
event you know you were very much back
in the public eye which is amazing
congratulations
on that um but uh the parking situation
to me
there's not a stealth way like kind of a
batman
way of kind of going underneath that i
think that you should investigate
and i'm thinking that if with you know
certainly your status that you could
sort of achieve that
um it involves kind of hanging a left on
victory
and then kind of you keep rolling and
then there's there's kind of a stealth
way that you can get underneath the
tunnel which i would highly recommend
okay very crucial information
who needs surface street parking this is
what you're saying that's
that's what i feel like you've earned it
thank you okay
good to know outstanding intel i will
check
with you it was a smooth little deal
you know i can imagine that that's a lot
better than parking up top
i'm not gonna surface street park come
on
nope okay i've got 18 years in the nfl
so i've got thank you coach
i appreciate that and then we'll then
when the schedule comes out
uh on may 12th i'll find out when you're
on the road
and uh and use your spot if you don't
lie right in there it'll just say
you know whatever rich eisen you know
we'll endow the parking
parking spot i love it thank you because
as you know
uh in your time in los angeles nothing
more important than knowing how to park
and when to park and of course
validation and i don't mean you're doing
a good job i mean validation that's the
sort of validation i'm talking about
so absolutely thank you coach greatly
appreciate the chat let's talk during
the summer again
congrats on your first draft take care
you bet that's brandon staley hc of the
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here